it'll take a long time for the town of a
Medici
to recover from last Wednesday's
devastating earthquake followed on
Cassini surveys the damage in the town
center turn on Cassini is mayor of Lyon
essa a community located about 30
kilometers away it didn't suffer much
quake damage at all it's like a really
serious accident on the freeway the car
in front of you got hit but you just
managed to avoid it the same thing
happened here the quake could have hit
us in Lyon s that's pretty scary and
we're just glad it didn't happen to us
the mayor and a few other
representatives of the town have come to
Amman to DJ'd to assess the damage for
themselves the quake destroyed the old
town center as well as some new villas
and apartment blocks people have
expressed serious concerns over building
standards in the region the builders
don't take the proper safety measures it
happens all the time they have no sense
of responsibility there are lots of
earthquakes in Italy and there will be
another sooner or later this situation
affects all of us right here right now
mayor Tong Cassini's town Lyon Esser
dates back to the Middle Ages it lies on
the other side of the mountains from
Amaterasu although damage was a lot less
here in last week's quake the ground
certainly shook as well that scared the
local residents because a lot of the
buildings are just as old and fragile as
those in America the 13th century
palaces and churches probably wouldn't
survive a strong earthquake
the mayor and some local officials are
putting together an emergency reaction
plan back in the 1970s and 80s they
started building lots of new homes but
the plans didn't include any earthquake
protection measures there were hardly
any controls that's one of the reasons
why so many people were killed and I'm
at reaching the mayor and a local
building officials say that few of the
structures in town have proper
earthquake protection but there's
apparently not much they can do about it
several years ago Maria Soave tried to
get a loan to make earthquake
improvements on her vacation home but
officials turned her down because she
wasn't a local resident Maria says
that's ridiculous if a building falls
down in an earthquake it doesn't matter
who owns it if you want to fix up your
home you should be able to regardless of
where you actually live that's
especially important for places like
this where we have lots of tourists the
mayor says about one-third of the
structures here are vacation homes and
need better earthquake protection we
have too many regulations and red tape
how are we going to make all these
buildings safe for the next quake I hope
we don't get another one anytime soon a
lot of sellers look like Maria's the
walls aren't very strong and there are
cracks in the foundation the churches in
Lyon essa are closed right now while
officials check for damage so services
are held outdoors
the mayor like many others praised that
the town will be spared the fate of a
Medici yes you wake up in the morning
and remember that an earthquake has hit
close by and killed many people it's an
awful feeling that many people here are
sharing the residents of Lyon essa were
lucky this time now they have to make
sure that their buildings will survive
the next earthquake